Ми йдемо по хутору Гойч.
Тут всього 11 хат.
Кажуть, колись було 30.
Потім деякі розібрали і
перевезли у Недашки, бо там жили.
Деякі самі розвалилися.
Тут навіть видно порожні
місця, де були хати.
Оце всі  хати  — реально покинуті,
ніхто в них не живе.
Слухай, я приїхала сюди,
а тут ніде немає садів.
На Поділлі у нас  всюди
біля хати був сад  величезний.
А тут я приїхала, і
навіть яблучка не можна з'їсти.
У нас там усюди чорнозем.
Там реально, плюнеш кісточку
від вишні, то вона й виросте.
А тут нічого не росте.
А я плювала, плювала – не вросло.
Дивіться, це – «волшебні какашки»,
вони роблять так, що дерева потім ростуть.
Бо у цій землі — піску, нічого
не росте, крім цієї трави.
У мене не прижилось лише пару,
а вкрали штук 5.
Посадила – 30.
Хто б тут не жив через 15-20 років,
йому буде приємно, що тут є фруктові дерева.
Тут взагалі все розвалено було.
Зараз оце піч, а раніше,
тут була гора цегли, все було вирвано.
Ось тут ми глиною помастили.
Нам не вистачило фарби тут
усе пофарбувати, але так також стильно.
Хотілося мати якесь своє місце.
От просто на Землі, десь в Україні, щоб кудись повертатися, особливо після мандрів.
Хотілось повертатись кудись у своє, додому.
Ну, і захотілося знайти щось таке,
де можна було б щось створити.
Це просто хутір, де колись жили люди.
Але уже нічого не відбувається.
Уже немає того життя,
яке я можу сюди привнести.
Отака була ідея — щоб весь
цей хутір зажив новим життям.
Я хочу зробити ремонт у хаті,
я хочу зробити баню,
щоб людям, які приїздять
погостювати, було де помитися.
Я хочу зробити майстерню, де можна
буде щось будувати, щось робити руками.
Можливо, це будуть просто вихідні, такі як зараз,
де люди будуть збиратися і щось створювати разом.
Це класна можливість, тому що дуже часто людям просто немає де познайомитися,
поспілкуватись, попрацювати, покопати, пошліфувати дошку.
А це дуже класна штука.
Працетерапія, насправді,  магічна річ.
Тут дуже хороше повітря і сприятливі
обставини: немає інтернету, хорошого зв'язку.
Це класно, це єднає людей.
Всі вимикають телефони і починають спілкуватися.
Це ж класно.
Мама моя народилася і виросла в селі.
А я уже народилася у місті.
Вона у 14 років сама з села втекла
довчатися в міській школі.
Вступила у Москві в університет,
у неї завжди було прагнення поїхати з села.
Пригадую, коли я їй сказала: «Мама,
я купила хату в селі»,
у телефоні була просто тиша.
«Угм», – мама.
– Я вже не пам'ятаю, що я й сказала.
– Я пам'ятаю «гііій».
– Так, нашо тобі те село?
– Я пам'ятаю одне — тільки ти ж
роботу на телебаченні не кидай!
– Так, це я завжди казала.
Якщо вона надумала – ти її не перебореш нічим.
Вона уперта як ...
– Баран, – я ж знаю, що ти хочеш сказати.
Ми приїхали сюди, я глянула, у мене аж серце заболіло.
У нас зовсім не такі хати. У нас все інакше.
У нас і хлів краще ніж ця хата.
Як вона їде в село, я пів ночі не сплю,
завжди думаю як там вона одна.
Кругом ліс, вовки і Катя ...
І от нещодавно я сказала, що я звільнилася з телебачення, я не хочу до чогось бути прив'язаною.
Мама це не може зрозуміти.
Я не хочу бути прив'язаною до місця, де вона виросла.
Я завжди дивувалася.
Господи, Катя, та усі з села вириваються,
вони йдуть у міста.
Там культура, там помитися можна,
чого ж ти йдеш назад у це болото?
Я приїхала, а тут і болота немає ніде.
Це у нас болото по коліно.
А тут пісок, плаж.
І йдеш у дощ, ти  чистенька йдеш.
В принципі, от їй так і подобається, що я можу зробити.
– Я не хочу робити це там, де мені зручно.
– Мені цікаво брати якісь нові цілі.
Тому  мені й не хотілося повертатися туди, де у мене уже є квартира, де мама мене чекає, чи ще хтось.
Це для мене було щось дуже нове і дуже цікаве.
Чим новіше і чим «незнаніше» тим мені і цікавіше.
Мені цікаво створити простір знайомства,
у мене були ідеї і плани про весь хутір.
Я собі уявляла це в масштабах населеного пункту.
Нехай  це обмежиться поки що моєю хатою.
Це буде така одна арт-дача, а не хутір.
Були причини пошкодувати про те, що приїхала.
Мене тут грабували.
Якось залізли в хату і вкрали мій рюкзак, у якому був ноутбук, який коштує більше ніж ця хата.
І у мене був відчай, а потім я така – добре,
Катя, це випробування.
Я повинна його пройти.
– Я вже думала, що ви й не приїдете.
– Як же я не приїду?
От як тільки якась сталася халепа,
як відразу стається якась хороша річ.
– А ми уже все посадили.
– У нас крашанки є, ось.
– Я стояла на зупинці, чекала на автобус, і
стоїть якась жінка, я на неї і не звертала уваги.
Вона ближче підійшла і каже:
«А ви Катя? Я вас так люблю».
– Мене познайомили з Катею через інтернет.
Мені сказали, що є тут така чудова дівчинка,
яка купила хату на Гойчі.
Я підписалася на її сторінку у фейсбуці.
Я їхала у Київ, стояла на зупинці, чекала на маршрутку.
Підходить дівчинка – я кажу: «Вибачте, а ви Катя?», – вона каже: «Так».
Я кажу: «Я вас люблю».
Я подивилась на ці очі, на ці ямки на щічках,
я сказала, що я буду її бульдозером.
Ми будемо пропагувати.
Нести культуру нашу в маси.
– Саме тут я часто зустрічалася з агресією людей,
з неприємними на мене реакціями.
Раніше я відповідала так само.
Коли до мене негативно – я так само «вмикала колючки» і теж починала сваритися.
А потім я зрозуміла, що це не працює.
Тобто, я не хочу перейняти їхні методи,
їхній світогляд, стати такою,
як тут звикли бачити світ
чи просто ставитися до людей.
Добро завжди перемагає.
Я вирішила, що буду просто зажди посміхатися.
Випромінювати тільки добро.
І не опускатись до якихось негативних,
злих, агресивних методів спілкування.
І це працює.
От реально, коли він до тебе приїжає: «Дивись,
щоб у мене не було проблем,
бо я тобі тут дрова привіз».
А я кажу: «Олеже, ну чого ви, які проблеми,
у всіх проблеми в житті.»
Я посміхнулася, і він такий теж посміхнувся і поїхав.
Коли до людини посміхаєшся, він не те що до тебе бурчить, він теж починає посміхатись.
Це магія, але це працює.